no sooner had japan declared victory
against covert 19 and relaxed its entry
requirements and the door is slammed
shut
its prime minister announcing on monday
that he would be taking no chances with
the new omnicron variant
regard to foreign visitors entering
japan from midnight of november 30th we
will ban entry from all parts of the
world
thailand and indonesia announced new
although less stringent bans on arrivals
from southern african nations
lockdowns have been devastating to the
tourist industry here and many southeast
asian nations will be reluctant to
impose blanket bans
the philippines started an ambitious
vaccination drive on monday to inoculate
more than nine million people in three
days
its travel ban of 14 nations includes
european countries where the new variant
has been found we are ready but we can
still buy more time we should delay this
as much as we can and really prepare the
health system's capacity prepare our
detect
isolate
treat reintegrate vaccinate
isolation strategies
one travel gateway that was opening up
rather than shutting down is the land
border between singapore and malaysia
three thousand people crossed this
border daily until march 2020 when it
was shut down stranding thousands so
pretty much i'm excited to go back to my
malaysia to my home country uh i know a
lot of families have been stuck in your
malaysia in singapore
this has been a good opportunity for me
to go back to
malaysia to visit my grandparents my
parents my families and stuff yeah
for now a special bus service will limit
visitors to 3 000 a day
as other borders around the region shut
down these travelers will be hoping this
journey isn't one way
tony chang al jazeera bangkok